perfect thank you very much so I know
more than a handful of people in the
room have seen earlier versions of this
this is joint work with Krishna schoo
who's sitting back there and will tell
us some new stuff about uber later today
and and at the end I'll try to inject
some parallel follow-on work that I did
with a couple of other colleagues at
eBay that relates to this general agenda
and and the general agenda is needs to
be the general agenda is on on the
effectiveness of reputation systems in
online marketplaces so so first let me
start with something that everybody here
in this room knows and that is that
platform markets or marketplaces are
fundamentally different from retailers
primarily because what they do is they
facilitate trade they don't trade
themselves they're not sellers so they
really don't control some key variables
such as inventory what do we hold prices
how do we ship and so on and so forth
but rather rely on the sellers to do all
that stuff and and naturally because of
that you're going to have a variance in
the quality of sellers who are on the
marketplace so you know whenever you buy
something from Amazon and if you buy it
from Amazon as the seller you know
exactly what's gonna happen right you're
gonna get it if you're a Prime member
within two days it's going to come in a
box that's gonna be well wrapped and
it's gonna be exactly what you wanted
and with probability point zero one
shit's gonna happen and it's gonna be
easy because you're gonna go online
you'll click three buttons and you'll
return it right when you buy from a
marketplace seller in particular a place
like eBay there's gonna be a lot more
variance in what might happen and this
is what reputation and feedback comes in
because many have said and I think the
best quote comes from the paper that
cristela raucous wrote about 12 13 years
ago that really this reputation is what
allowed these marketplaces to flourish
without it people would just worry too
much about the asymmetric information be
it moral hazard or adverse selection
and we know that eBay introduced it it's
used by Tao Bali Airbnb uber everybody
uses some form of reputation and in fact
you could even relate this to the more
broad area of product reviews in that
you know Amazon or Yelp or TripAdvisor
about the quality of products not
necessarily a particular seller and and
more recently I think a lot of platforms
and I think with some reasonable
rationality behind it have argued that
that really platforms are good self
regulatory mechanisms because you know
the platform wants quality to be good
you know we don't need government to
regulate this the reputation system will
take care of the regulation and and so
on but of course for reputation systems
to work reputation measures should first
of all accurately reflect the quality
and buyers should correctly perceive
this reputation to quality mapping and
and and really in this paper what we're
gonna take aim at both of these issues
we really can't do too much about the
second thing except from you know
anecdotally talk about what what seems
to be out there and you'll see what I
mean but we will be able to provide some
some pretty appealing evidence that
reputations don't seem to accurately
measure the quality of the transactions
so so here's one way of describing the
problem of reputation right so this
comes from a cartoon that Chris found
right so five stars it only has one
review four and a half stars excellent
four stars okay and everything else is
crap and and I think this resonates with
with a lot of online platforms so so the
question is what's what's going on here
and how are we contributing to this
problem so so because the length of the
talk I'm gonna skip a few you know
things in the introduction and dive into
the paper this will again a little bit
follow what Kiara see you know this is
kind of a more specific paper and not so
much an overview of a series of of
different agendas but but you will see
there I'll talk about two papers and and
how they reflect to this general agenda
so first I think we're highlighting
issues that really are
scene from traditional platform models
and what I mean by that there's a large
literature in economics on economic
platforms and that literature is 95 to
98% concerned with how do you price
these I have buyers I have sellers I
have this network externality if I want
the platform to flourish where do I put
the prices in order to create this
better network interaction and by and
large there's no discussion of
asymmetric information or what we will
refer to as quality spill overs or
reputational externalities across
sellers because the thing is and then
that Kris and I believe is if I'm a
seller on eBay and you buy for me and
you have a crappy experience in your
head you're not saying oh eBay is
awesome you know Steve dotted Ellis
1-2-3 is a horrible seller in people's
mind is going to be I bought something
on eBay and I was screwed and I'm not
happy with eBay and we're going to show
some evidence that that that is indeed
true the second news we're going to
highlight some issues that are missing
from the traditional models of
reputation and and here I'm as you know
guilty as anyone else who's written in
the field of the economics of reputation
this is work that I did in my
dissertation which is why this topic has
always been near and dear to me you know
when you write down an economic model of
reputation typically it's going to be
some repeated game or dynamic model of
adverse selection where people do some
kind of base updating about history visa
vie the type of seller that they're
buying from or if it's pure repeated
games it's just you know kind of a folk
theorem bootstrap equilibrium if you'll
be good I'll pay you and as long as I
pay you you'll be good and and in those
models we assume that the reputation or
the history is exogenous ly generated
okay so on one extreme you have the
perfect information models or oh sorry
perfect recall models where all the
histories of the pasts are there for
everyone to observe it every new
participant in this game sees the
histories and knows exactly how to do
the inference and and of course these
are equilibrium models where people
understand what they mean and they act
accordingly and everybody is best
responding to their beliefs
in reality reputation is not given out
there either perfectly or even
imperfectly with some noise
it is user-generated content so we need
to understand something about how these
reputation measures are created in order
to understand how to interpret them and
then of course is the question is are
people correctly interpreting them which
is outside the scope of equilibrium
analysis and as an economist that would
be you know blasphemy to even even
consider that as an option but but I
will at least show some respect to that
possible idea and furthermore what this
is going to do is going to cause these
reputation systems to either be skewed
or or just completely uninformative and
the question then is how could platforms
deal with that and what we're gonna
argue is that what marketing or
platforms need to do is to augment the
feedback system with their own ability
to self-regulate and we do believe that
these platforms have the incentive to
self-regulate because you know this ties
in very nicely to some of the things
that susan said and inner talk in that
you know you have the short run in the
long term and of course for these
platforms to survive they really have to
care about the long term so it is in
their interest to provide good
experience to both sides of the market
and what we're gonna argue is that these
marketplaces can find information in
their data that could augment and maybe
even replace reputation systems more
generally and what we're going to do
here which is unlike a typical economics
paper we're not gonna have some optimal
solution like in a theory paper but
rather we're gonna offer a proof of
concept and what we strongly believe and
I think I'm speaking for both Chris and
me and Chris will correct me if I'm
wrong at some level this is a bit of an
engineering problem okay what works best
for eBay may not be the best solution
for uber may not be the best solution
for Airbnb this will be a function of
the kind of data they collect the kind
of transactions they have and so on and
and you'll see what I mean by that and
and last but not least we're going to
suggest this engineering implementation
to go through the search that
in other words we know from a lot of the
literature in and that computer
scientists have done on on search and
some economists that you know the more
prominently or displayed I mean Susan
mentioned this and one of the
experiments they did when they switch
the first and the third rank and you saw
the amount of traffic that drops so that
means that if I as a platform believe
that certain sellers of lower quality if
I dump them further down the search the
likelihood that people will click on
them is much lower and in fact you might
even argue that you know in some longer
run with better personalization you
might even be able to do this in a
personalized level so for example if
Ramesh is new to my site and he comes
and and then you know I noticed that
he's a new buyer I might want to give
him the red carpet you know so gloves
awesome experience and I he's gonna
search for some query I won't even show
him sellers that I'm not that sure about
on the other hand if if how comes and
he's an experienced eBay user and say
you know what I know that hell knows how
to read between the lines I'm gonna show
him the back alleys of my marketplace
and and he buy so much that if he's not
gonna get a good deal he won't hold that
against me the eBay platform because he
knows so much about eBay right so we
could even think of of personalizing
that so so let me give you the this is
going to be our theory slide okay this
is the conceptual framework that we're
taking to the data on eBay and and that
is think of a buyer as a dynamic
decision maker some Bayesian dynamic
decision maker that comes to eBay with
some prior belief I'm not sure how good
a Bay is let me try it out i buy a
product I have an experience I'm unhappy
I might decide I don't like eBay I'm
leaving I'm never coming back or I'll
buy a second time I buy a second time
I'll get an experience I'll update my
belief I might leave the platform or I'd
buy again so really you could think of
any particular decision maker as a
probability distribution over these
terminal nodes and and basically we're
looking at how will this person proceed
dynamically where of course the the
underlying
truth of such an economic decision-maker
would be the better my experiences that
Evan given any given moment the more
likely it is that I will continue
purchasing and second the further down I
am along this tree the less likely any
given experience will matter so you know
I'll have a pretty diffuse prior early
on but if I'm on transaction number a
hundred and I get screwed you know what
I might say hey [ __ ] happens I'll
continue whereas if I get screwed on the
first transaction I may be a lot more
likely to attribute that to the quality
of the platform Ilya I'm not going to
rule that out this is going to be
included in the model you yes that
that's true so so again from from after
the slide everything is going to be
empirical but we will control for the
reputation in the empirics so we're very
much aligned for that and in fact I'll
show you something in the in one of the
regressions that I think is going to be
you know initially counterintuitive but
then when you think about the issue of
selection it won't be regarding exactly
selection on reputation so so the
question is what could buyers use
exactly as Elia said in terms of this
reputation to form some initial
expectation so you know just I do this
in every time I give one of these talks
how many people here have bought on eBay
just out of curiosity okay so this
audience is more than average I'm not
gonna ask you how many people buy on
Amazon because everybody should raise
their hand if you're not raising your
hand you either didn't listen to me or
you're lying right so and and and and
there's a good reason for that but
that's for lunch or beer and uh so so
when you go to ebay we know that buyers
choose to leave feedback that could be
positive negative neutral or nothing I
could choose not to leave any feedback
this is what eBay does with that data it
offers two measures of reputation for
the seller one is the percent positive
which is the number of positives divided
by positives plus negatives and the
second is a seller feedback score which
is the number of positives minus the
number of negative
so the more you sell the more positives
you get the score is growing basically
you know unless you start just getting
negative after negative which as we'll
show you is very unlikely and this is
just the percent another thing that eBay
does with the reputation they have their
own standards so for example I'll show
you a bad a seller might get an internal
eBay badge that says this is a trusted
seller so this is a ebay trusted seller
etrs badge that eBay uses with this data
and other data to you know basically
give people some kind of stamp of
approval so I'll show you an example of
two sellers so here's one seller this
seller's name is samne so for you see it
over here this seller has a reputation
score of 317 so positive minus negative
equals 317 and positive / positive plus
negative is 96.9% so you know this is a
group of extremely accomplished people
and you know I know that in the u.s.
quite a lot of people get a 4.0 GPA is
as undergrads who continue on to the
kind of careers that people like you
have but anyone here who comes from
outside the US is very unlikely to have
an undergrad GPA of 96.9 okay so so in
some absolute terminology right 96.9 is
a very high number okay here's another
seller this seller Owen this was for a
MacBook and you see that it's used here
I have a MacBook that's new this seller
blue blue Tech USA has a reputation
score of 40 4949
has 99.5% positive instead of ninety six
point nine again he knows that a big
difference well that that's a good
question this is a top rated + seller so
the seller has the ebay badge and and
this is you know what the buyer sees
every time they will click on an item
they will see the reputation of the
seller so the question is you know
what's a good number well this is the
distribution of feedback on ebay okay a
hundred percent the rate is unweighted
the
is weighted by transaction volume so you
see that there's a huge number in fact
over 60% of unweighted sellers have a
hundred percent positive by the way I
started this graph at 98%
okay so ninety six point nine is you
know like in the fifth percentile of the
distribution okay so this number that
sounds pretty impressive is completely
unimpressive in fact it's pretty poor
when you think about eBay the mean is
99.3 the tenth percentile is ninety
seven point eight so of course there are
two ways to interpret this data one
might be that everything is working
perfectly
once a seller screws up a couple of
times nobody buys from them anymore they
die off the platform gets rid of them
and they're gone okay alternatively this
is just you know Lake Wobegon on
steroids everybody is above average
everybody is awesome so here's a little
bit of evidence oh go ahead yes this is
all post that okay this is this is way
post that yes yeah it's still pretty bad
and that's a that's a cool study then
yeah so I mean what David mentioned ebay
you used to be able to leave two-sided
and you know I'll actually get to this
in a second because retaliation was one
of the issues that that came up with so
so either you know this is Nirvana or
its heavily biased and and here's some
evidence that this is not Nirvana this
is not this great site where the bad
people get kicked out and so on so so as
I mentioned earlier positive feedback an
average of ninety nine point three of
the remaining point seven about point
four is negative feedback and point
three is neutral feedback I'm gonna jump
to the third one the fourth one dispute
filed this is where an ebay spire try to
resolve something with the seller at
least most likely tried because you only
could file a dispute after you try that
was unhappy and went through the
process of filing a formal dispute with
eBay that is a non-trivial amount of
work okay whereas leaving a negative
feedback is a trivial thing you know
click send end of story
so why kind of puzzling fact is how come
the propensity of filing a dispute is
almost three times the propensity of
leaving negative feedback well we dug
even deeper and and I'll mention this at
the end what we could do with this look
at post transaction emails it turns out
that almost 9% of transactions have an
email sent by the buyer to the seller
it's actually an internal message after
the transaction why would you want to
send the seller I mean it could be a
user saying hey this is awesome thank
you I love you right well with a little
bit of simple NLP baby NLP you could
look for words like late broken where is
it
disappointed and so on and you get that
almost 10 times as many negative
feedbacks there are ex post messages
from buyers to sellers that say
something didn't work for me so so the
question is why well here's one reason
that that might happen so this is
article from a few years ago eBay
shopper says he was harassed by seller
Colorado State University student wants
to return bike gets recorded threats the
first message saved on his voicemail
don't you play games with me god damn
you all follow you to your grave you
know everything about me said
Blackwelder that's a student my phone
number my address my name it's a little
scary so this is a student toboggan you
know left negative feedback the seller
was very upset and started threatening
him there is an instant in the UK about
four years ago and one in the US two or
three years ago that that I that I saw
where sellers sued buyers who left them
negative feedback for defamation
okay and and this doesn't only happen on
eBay you know here's a yelp review
okay so last week Fairfax Virginia jury
found that home owner Jane Perez defamed
her contractor when she wrote a pair of
scathing reviews of the
services accusing him of watching her
home blah blah blah right this kind of
reminds you of the McDonald's coffee
incidents for those who are old enough
to remember that you know with all this
crazy tort law well of course if you are
a buyer and you read something like this
and then you buy some item on eBay say
for 15 bucks and it's not exactly what
you wanted and you try with the seller
and doesn't get resolved and you kind of
think should I leave a negative feedback
and you reach something like this and
you're most likely reaction is excuse my
french [ __ ] this I'm leaving the site
okay I just don't want to deal with the
eBay anymore and and of course what that
would create is this hazard that people
with negative experiences even if they
stay on eBay they might not report them
because they're worried about these
things and and of course they might just
leave without reporting them and then
we're missing a lot of information so so
if that's the case if leaving feedback
is a hassle then that alone doesn't
imply that it's biased but if the cost
of leaving feedback depends on the
quality of the transaction then it would
be biased so what do I have in mind here
you know we are in Berkeley and for
those who are non economists Berkeley is
kind of the Haven of behavioral
economics so if you wanted to write some
behavioral economic model that some
people are you know so they have social
preferences right I like to provide a
public good because I'm sure you all
know in economics everybody's the
selfish bastard and nobody does anything
for society but imagine if you have
preferences I want to help other people
you could think of some positive utility
or negative costs that people have from
leaving feedback right so that means
that some people who are more social
minded leave feedback others who are
less social minded don't leave feedback
if the only thing that determines
whether or not you leave feedback is
your benefit or cost of leaving feedback
but that doesn't depend on the quality
of the transaction then feedback won't
be biased let's say only 50% of the
people leave feedback but it's still an
unbiased estimator of the truth
however the suggestive evidence of the
hassle of you know the lawsuits and so
on means that if I have a positive
experience I'm okay leaving feedback if
I have a negative experience
my cost of leaving feedback is suddenly
higher because of this retaliation this
brings the bias in which then results in
the obvious claim that leaving negative
feedback is more costly and because of
all the reasons I told you and that
implies now that silence is a
combination of two things it's a
combination of selfish bastards and
unselfish people who would have left
feedback if it were positive but I'm not
going to leave feedback if it's negative
and that in turn means that we could use
the silence as a measure of negativity
because there's information in the
silence and and and this goes to a nice
paper by Della Rocca sand and wood in
2005 were they conjectured that silence
is a problem and they propose a kind of
two-sided reputation Econometrica model
to try to reveal how much bias there is
but you know as David mentioned eBay
changed the reputation system in 2008
now sellers cannot leave negative
feedback on buyers anymore so they're a
canoe metric method just doesn't work we
have the benefit of we were in eBay we
had access to the eBay data so we
actually could go and determine these
things directly so let me give you an
idea of what we did here so remember
that percent positive positive divided
by positive plus negative silence was
missing let's just create a new metric
will call it effective percent positive
and that's just going to be number of
positives divided by number of
transactions so I'm taking silence I'm
throwing it into the denominator and and
I'm therefore holding it against the
seller so here would be an example
imagine seller a and seller B both have
99 positives and one negative so if I
ignore the silence they would look
exactly identical they would both have a
a percent positive and 99 percent one
divided by sorry 99 divided by 100
however I'm going to assume that seller
a for example has a hundred and twenty
transactions and seller B has a hundred
and fifty transactions so now when I
divide positive / total transactions I
get eighty 2.5% epp for seller a and 66%
for seller B and the claim is that
seller a is a higher
Celer than seller be okay that's what
we're gonna try to establish using our
data so first thing is to look at the
distribution of EPP and suddenly we get
them something that looks like a signal
right you don't have that hockey stick
of almost everybody has a hundred and
and there's almost nothing below
ninety-eight percent here we have a nice
distribution with some some spread but
but we're left with a question is this
really a measure of quality so what are
we going to do what we did is we took a
cohort of ebay buyers and we track them
over about three years so how do we do
this we took new users who join eBay any
time in 2011 we took 10% of all new
users that gave us a sample of nine
hundred and thirty-five thousand buyers
so almost a million buyers they had to
sign up and purchase an item within 30
days of signing up by the way we
replicated this analysis for starting
years 2008 2009 2010 the results are
almost quantitatively identical so this
is pretty robust in terms of the impact
then what we did is for every such buyer
we tracked all their usage until May 31
2014 so on average we have about three
years per person for some people little
more for some people little less and
that gives us over 15 million
transactions that these people purchased
the data that we have of course is going
to include this is the internal data so
it's price quantity item category who
the seller was what kind of sale
mechanism auction or fixed price and so
on then since we have all these 15 plus
million transactions each one of them we
could identify with the seller that
gives us a total of 1.8 million sellers
who sold these 50 million items to these
almost 1 million buyers and for each one
of those we have their information which
is their feedback score their percent
positive and then what we do is since
eBay doesn't have that in their original
data for every seller at any transaction
we calculate their epp okay so we add
that as another seller characteristic at
that moment and then we're going to
apply this data to our conceptual
framework
namely you know you're purchasing
dynamically and we're going to ask how
does a PP affect your behavior so so
this is one of the advantages of this
paper again because we just had access
to the internal data typically empirical
papers that looked at eBay transactions
and try to see the effect of reputation
on prices or stuff like that they you
scrape data and and there's a lot of
problems using scrape data in terms of
endogeneity and so on and so forth we're
taking what economists call a revealed
preference approach I'm going to look at
the behavior of people as a function of
the epp of the sellers that they
interact with and the important thing is
to remember that EPP is not observable
so if you remember when I when I went to
a seller here okay
EP P is not listed anywhere so I can't
use that to select who I want to buy
from and therefore the variation in EPP
will be considered to be exogenous
and then I'm gonna show you experimental
results where it really is exogenous
because we did a treatment control so so
this is kind of a snapshot if you will
of that distribution along that decision
tree so remember some people buy one
item some people will exit after two
items so we took that three period
three-year period and all the people who
only bought once it's as if they were on
that first branch of the tree and they
decided they're not buying anymore some
people bought twice so as you could see
over here a big majority of people I'm
not a majority of everyone but 38% buy
one item and never buy again on ebay
which is a very high number the median
is two the mean is about 16 purchases
and but we see it has a very long tail
right so so the max for example is 19
thousand three hundred and fifty nine
this is someone who registered and just
for the next three years that the
computer and just bought stuff so that's
what it seems like I'm just going to
quickly skip over this but this is just
a matrix that shows that there is indeed
the scope for externalities namely if
I'm a seller and I treat you poorly that
will affect your belief about someone
else because most people the more they
buy the more sellers
so people are not coming to Ebay it's
not like I go to Ebay and I heard that
Ilya sells on ebay I'm looking for Ilya
and then once I'm there I just buy from
Elia that doesn't seem to be what people
are doing so so let me tell you how
we're gonna measure the effect of
quality on exit rates and how we're
gonna try to look at this issue of the
externality namely how you're affected
by one seller about what your behavior
is not only towards that seller but
towards eBay as a whole so so as I said
we're using this revealed preference
approach so we are going to define a
variable which is say Y IJ T and yit so
Y IJ T is going to be 1 if buyer I
bought transaction T from seller J and
after that return to seller J we're
typically going to use 180 days we've
done robustness if it's only 90 days or
a whole year and and again the results
don't change very much so this is really
looking at how a current transaction
affects my future purchase behavior on
eBay and yit is just going to be the
same thing but instead of returning to
the same seller it's just returning to
eBay as a whole well J appears over so
this is the probability that Y that
person I after transaction T returns to
eBay and we will control for the seller
J's repiy P and a whole bunch of other
seller characteristics so J is included
here but the idea is here we're looking
at the transaction and not the
transaction and the seller that's why we
use this notation then bi t bar is just
a vector of buyer characteristics so for
example how many transactions they
completed which is a measure of how
experienced they are and you know other
seller characteristic other buyer
characteristics we have a vector of
seller characteristics for example the
feedback score the percent positive and
and other characteristics that we could
measure D Bar T is a vector of
transaction characteristics like is it
an auction or a fixed price what the
price was cat
and so on and in a way the difference
between these two captures this idea of
how much of it is towards the same
seller how much as it is towards eBay as
a whole so here are the the results from
these main regressions this is the same
seller aggression this is the eBay
regression and and let me tell you what
what our key interest here is so recall
the way I wrote it here I just wrote it
as a linear regression but what we've
really done is something a little more
nonparametric so we took the EPP and
divided into first quartiles second
quartile third and fourth and the first
quartile is the excluded variable here
and here the other three quartile so the
excluded one is like the crappiest EPP
right who we believe are the lowest
quality sellers better even better and
best and what we see over here are the
marginal probabilities of returning to
eBay so what you see is that a seller
from the second quartile relative to the
lowest quartile you're half a percent
more likely to return to the same seller
you're almost two percent more likely to
return to eBay if you're in the third
quartile relative to the first returning
to the same seller is about two percent
2.1 percent and almost three percent
more likely to return to ebay and if
you're in the highest quartile returning
to the same seller is about two percent
more likely and about four percent more
likely to return to ebay so this
difference really shows you that when a
seller treats a buyer well the impact on
eBay is larger than the impact on the
seller itself which shows that that
externality is really present the other
thing that shows you is that EPP really
is a revealed preference measure of
quality when I show people higher EPP
sellers they are more likely to return
to the seller and to eBay so this really
is through the revealed preference
capturing some measure of satisfaction
right you know if I always kind of felt
that the right name for this paper would
have been exit voice and loyalty and
online mark
for those who are familiar with the
Hirshman famous book on exit voice and
loyalty right so here we're using exit
right you're leaving eBay as a measure
of dissatisfaction this is what I
promised I wanted to talk about when
Ilya asked about reputation so so for
the percent positive we do the same
thing you know we know that the mean is
99 well it's almost ninety nine point
four so we exclude anything below the
mean and then we include a dummy four
between the mean and a hundred percent
and then another dummy just for a
hundred percent and what you see over
here is that the coefficient on these
two is actually negative now if you
would have interpreted this as a causal
result this would say when you buy from
a higher percent positive seller you're
more likely not to come back to eBay
okay so when you kind of think of it
that way it makes absolutely no sense
because you would expect that positive
you know a higher positive percentage is
probably a better seller well the
problem is that that the percent
positive is observable to to the seller
to the buyer and buyers could select on
that so then what would happen
so Elia has a almost 13 year old
daughter imagine that in two or three
years he decides that he wants to buy
her a classic vintage Gibson Les Paul
guitar okay you could look for it on
Amazon you're not gonna find it because
you don't find classic vintage stuff
there so he has to come to eBay and
imagine that Elia doesn't buy on eBay
because he doesn't trust eBay but this
is the only place he could find it so he
will come to eBay with two things in
mind one he wants to minimize risk - he
doesn't like eBay so he's not planning
to come back so what does he do to
minimize risk he looks for sellers that
are a hundred percent positive - he
doesn't come back I get this negative
correlation between selecting high
positive and not coming back to eBay so
this is a selection story not a causal
interpretation whereas these because
they cannot select on it our causal now
of course oh well let me just quickly go
over this what we do over here so
remember that dynamic Bayesian tree if I
take it seriously the implication should
be the further I am down the tree the
less likely I should be affected by the
quality of the transaction so so this is
the distribute here we're showing you
the estimated effect of EPP interacted
with whether this is your first
transaction second third fourth fifth
and the theory says this should be kind
of downward sloping now we see that for
the first transaction it's actually
pretty low and then it kind of jumps up
and then we have this nice monotonicity
that theory predicts we really feel that
we can't say much about the first
transaction because again those people
who come to eBay with the mindset of I'm
never going to come back they will also
not be that affected by the quality of
the transaction because they have this
very strong vindication so if I kind of
exclude the first purchase we get this
pattern that seems consistent with that
idea of a dynamic Bayesian decision
maker so we basically include a dummy
for the interaction between your
experience and the EPP which is which is
kind of like running separate
regressions so so for this one the dummy
is one times the EPP of that transaction
for people for whom this is their first
purchase to estimate this that's the
same dummy but for people who are the
second purchase third fourth fifth so of
course you might wonder well what could
we do with this what could they do with
this what we're arguing is that that
what the online platform could do is say
oh well we have something in the data
that we could use to estimate seller
quality well if that's the case then we
could do two things we could show it to
the set buyers and say hey here's
another measure of seller quality maybe
you want to use this well the problem is
if you kind of think of sellers
harassing buyers if now sellers
understand that eBay is using this
measure sellers might just say leave me
feedback leave me feedback leave me
feedback and they're really going to her
people so instead maybe eBay could keep
this secret not tell people what they're
doing and at the end I'll say a word or
two about this very Disick walibi areum
like thought which which is troublesome
and and not use kind of the hard hand of
Amazon which is anybody who screws up
we're gonna kick them off the market
place or the quite Liz s fair approach
that eBay has always taken where anybody
could sell on eBay but look at a middle
ground where if I've identified sellers
that are not that good let me demote
them in the search and that's the exact
experiment that we did where you know
here if you go to eBay you search for
MacBook Air you're going to get a list
of sellers well what if I now use EPP
and decide oh the most relevant computer
is this guy but he doesn't have a high
EPP so maybe I'll move him to number
four and then I'll elevate everybody
else okay and vice-versa so so we ran
this experiment and between December
14th and in 2011 and January 2nd 2012
where there was a 10% amount of traffic
that came to eBay that they got a
version of the search algorithm that
promoted EPP okay but it didn't promote
it by much because you know Chris and I
cans like let's promote EPP and then
they have 20 other groups of eBay that
these guys care about this and those
guys care about that so you know they're
not gonna elevate EPP dramatically so
you could see the distribution of the
weighted EPP across the pages between
treatment and control so this is control
this is treatment
it was very mild it was only about a
three percentage point change in EPP so
so that gives us a very small amount of
variation but even with that small
amount of variation we were able to get
quite strong estimates I'm gonna quickly
run through this the two most
interesting things are that one we get a
strong effective EPP in different
specifications and and they're quite
consistent with the reduced form
estimates from the observational data
but the second thing that's interesting
is of course because they did such a
small
change if we look at the difference
between conversion rates and treatment
and control it was a pretty flat zero so
this is the estimate on every day of the
conversion rate and you see a pretty
flat zero this is negative 0.1 percent
positive 0.1% so they really didn't
sacrifice any relevance now of course if
they had more of an extreme shift of EPP
they may have sacrificed a little more
relevance so so so let me jump ahead to
spend the last three minutes on
follow-up work that I did with Dimitri
master of and Leuven Meyer who are at
eBay and this little note came out in EC
15 so remember that thing about the
messages right so should buyer ever send
a cell or a message post the transaction
well here's an example of a message that
surprised me that they exist but you
have some people like this right hello
and good morning I'm glad to tell you
that the two items arrived safely today
and very happy because I needed for a
dinner party
thanks a lot kind regards okay this is
really someone who has the time and
energy to express themselves on the
other hand you know I purchased two
pairs of shorts from you at the same
time one pair gold red which I have
received in one pair which I haven't
received so I should still be receiving
a refund okay this is not good news and
a buyer who experiences this clearly
didn't experience a good transaction so
what we did then is first of all look at
the information in the messages this is
a spline plot and an internal metric
that eBay has on customer satisfaction
and and what you see over here is that
transactions with no messages only about
4% of them have some indication of
dissatisfaction so this could be a
negative feedback I didn't tell you
about the DSR as the detailed selling
ratings these are these stars that eBay
use that's another metric that they have
or even some kind of dispute so that
adds up to about 4% if there is a
neutral message something where we
didn't find any of those negative words
it jumps up to about 12% of trends of
transactions that actually have some
indication of dissatisfaction and if we
identify the
with a negative words it jumps up to
over 30% so then what we could do is
something very similar to what Chris and
I did and we could say you know what if
Ramesh is a seller and two out of every
hundred transactions he gets a negative
email he has a two percent negative
email rate and if I'm a different seller
and five out of every hundred hundred
transactions I get a negative email I
have a five percent negative email rate
so that means that I'm a worse seller
with that metric here what we show is
that negative metrics so a bigger number
is a worse metric this is kind of a
opposite to EPP here we have the
probability of a poor experience
indicator and we see this very nice
increase in that probability and then we
did exactly what Chris and I did with
the reveal preference approach we
couldn't replace EPP with this new
measure and see how does that affect the
exit rate and that had a very strong
impact and here's what surprised us it
has as big an impact when included in
the regressions independently as EPP so
suddenly I have two signals that seem to
have a lot of disparate information and
one signal alone doesn't capture all
this information so so you know I won't
go into more details but but that's
another issue in the indie like here's
another piece of data that this platform
has that they could use to detect seller
quality and use it to rank sellers so to
conclude you know platforms will face a
lot of challenges of asymmetric
information because of the variety of
sellers that sell on it there are going
to be externalities across these sellers
and bias that limit the effectiveness of
feedback and and what we think we
contributed here is you know clearly
uncover these biases and show the
reputational externalities suggest this
active screening using the search
mechanism and and you know this email
stuff now what I think is is really
important here is to understand that
these marketplaces do have an incentive
to self-regulate so they really do have
an incentive to use this kind of
engineering data science to pick up
measures of seller quality and use them
in their ranking but but this is kind of
going back to what I said which is kind
of blasphemy for economics I really
believe that there is an element of
disequilibrium that needs to be played
here so you know I know there so I spent
half my life in Israel and I know there
you know at least the critical mass of
Israelis if it's computer science and
economics and and there's a whole area
of electronic warfare so I don't know
many of you know you know there's
electronic warfare and there's counter
and counter right so you're always
trying to stay one step ahead of the of
the enemy and I think there's going to
be something similar that marketplaces
need to think about here is how do we
create mechanisms that we understand how
we're doing the ranking and a great
example is Google score right Google's
Quality Score Google never tells anyone
how they're doing it because if they
tell people how they're doing it they're
worried that people are going to game
the system and manipulate it so I think
the same thing is going to be true about
quality ranking of sellers on these
platforms and that's the only way they
will be able to get a better selection
and a better ranking of sellers in order
to give buyers a better experience
looking for the biases in a preferred
signal and she was helpful I take your
point about the disequilibrium do you
think that's also kind of an interesting
research question even in the
equilibrium model with somehow talked to
the design a system that may be
deliberately uses randomization to make
it difficult for the seller to make
threats trying to change the signals
provided by the buyer yeah that that's
an excellent question because with
randomization we could kind of
reintroduce the equilibrium right just
kind of some mixed strategy on behalf of
the platform that may be you know kind
of like in
Holmstrom and other models of signal
jamming right so we're trying to jam the
signals so people can't infer it so that
might be a way to proceed theoretically
and see kind of what those kind of
algorithms might you presumably some
buyers only leave positive feedback but
there are others who actually leave lots
of negative feedback does your
regression capture that I might want to
take more seriously so so the answer is
no and I think we even have a paragraph
in the paper on that and that is that
you know I should as a platform use
machine learning and other algorithms to
figure out that your feedback is more
correlated with what I think is true
seller quality and now I'm going to
overweight your feedback and Eric only
leaves positive I'll just ignore him
right so absolutely yes and that goes
back to that little point I made this is
an engineering problem as much as an
economic design problem and that's why I
think you know there are a lot of
interesting things that for an applied
engineering approach are going to be
interesting and no ay-e-e-ah referee is
going to be interested in
you know publishing something like that
there are laws yeah very question a
little bit related to the talk that
Susan was giving at the end I'm maybe
testing this morning do you have a
sensitive cost-benefit perspective what
it would cross smooth pretty surprising
how many transactions have some flavor
of negativity the transactions when they
have a negative transaction did you get
some sense of so so we so here's what we
could do and here's what we can't do
so what we could do is do a
counterfactual of if eBay promotes this
you know EPP measure for example what
will that do for shifting the
distribution of exit along those so that
we could do quite accurately given the
estimates from our regression because
the experiment that we ran didn't have
enough variation in EPP to cause a
reduction in the conversion rate we
don't have a cost so right now the
estimates we have say oh the cost of
doing this is zero if we had a more
aggressive change in the experiment that
we could have seen a drop in the PP in
the conversion rate then we could have
done a short run versus long run
analysis exactly along these lines right
now we just don't have a short run cost
you're absolutely so when we suggested
running this experience then the first
thing people think well our algorithm is
optimized you know to do the right thing
why do you want to muck around with it
because it's optimized for conversion
not for customer lifetime value and that
goes exactly to the issues that Susan
raised about short versus long